okay i want to show you how to fill a
klein bottle can a klein bottle be
filled does a klein bottle have volume
you ask a mathematician and they'll say
well
a klein bottle doesn't really have any
volume well it's a topological shape
this doesn't have volume but wait a
second it looks like it has volume well
if you ask a topologist does a measuring
cup have volume
they'll probably tell you
no does
a sphere have volume yep no matter how
you know you know
four pi r cube
whatever it has a volume
it divides the universe into an outside
and an inside and no matter how you
stretch and contort it if you shrink it
if you make it bigger it'll always have
a volume
well
a piece of paper i can make it into sort
of a cup somehow or another but it'll
always occupy very little volume or you
know in the limit none
likewise a bag
right i can put stuff in
i put stuff into it
i'd even put stuff that has volume into
it
but
it doesn't divide the universe it
doesn't divide the universe into two
parts
if i were in outer space
all of these grapes
would float out
a bag doesn't divide our universe into
two parts
this is related closely
to a two-dimensional problem called the
jordan curve problem which asks a cool
question of
is there a difference between
that curve
and this other curve this encloses an
area
this doesn't enclose an area turns out
to be a surprisingly difficult thing to
prove
and the mathematician camille jordan who
finally solved it was a real smart
character
in the same way to a topologist the
question is
does something divide the universe into
the outside in the inside
a klein bottle
even a three-dimensional klein bottle an
immersion like this
well the air on the inside of it can
easily escape to the outside
sort of
in
this cup
this measuring cup which says oh
500 milliliters over here a physical
volume to a topologist they just melt it
down flatten it out and say oh this is
homeomorphic
to a disk
it has no volume a disk has no volume so
be careful
when you talk to mathematicians in the
kitchen
don't don't don't don't let them near
your recipe book
having said that
you know sphere has a volume
a doughnut a taurus has a volume
but a klein bottle doesn't have a
mathematical volume
got that what about a physical volume
well this obviously you can put
you know
in america it's possible to put 16
ounces
of water in it everywhere else in the
world you could put 500 milliliters into
it
got that
so if a klein bottle
doesn't have a mathematical volume does
it have a physical volume
well the way i make these
the answer is well sort of yes
you can fill a klein bottle
with water
and throw some dye in it also you can't
pull that out well yeah i can pour it
out oops pour some water out go through
here put the
glug
pour it out
out it goes
drop by drop
essentially it's vapor locked it won't
so yep
i can get water in i can get water out
so like the measuring cup your klein
bottle in the real world only has volume
depending on its orientation in gravity
that's right another way of thinking of
it is
this
measuring cup depends on gravity
to hold
to hold water
in the absence of gravity or if the
gravitational field is inverted hey it
doesn't hold water anymore i got that um
likewise
a klein bottle
but
a sphere
hey this is if you put water in here
it'll stay in there
no matter what so
how do you fill a klein bottle
well
step one for me i'll put a drop of food
coloring in
boop
which is way more than you need a little
bit of water in a few drops it'll go
right through notice my fingers have
already been dyed
so okay i got some got some water in
there
problem is every time i pour water in it
vapor locks and i only get sort of this
much water in so come on over i'll dunk
it under water and show you
how to fill a klein bottle with water
along with a little bit of blue in it
dunk it under water
and wiggle it around each time a bubble
of air comes out
and with each bubble of air
a little bit of water
comes in
let's get a bubble of air
and held under water long enough
so you're doing like a sort of a 360 are
you to get the bubble yeah
and if each bubble is about a milliliter
or two
eventually
with each bubble leaving
conservation of something tells me that
a bubble-sized bit of water is going in
still pretty slow oh come on it's not
slow this is fast compared to the age of
the universe this is speed compared to
even something as rapid as global
warming this is fast stuff here
not just fast but
you know compared to the rate it takes
to make a klein bottle it's
enormously fast
um you could use an aquarium pump you
could use a water pump and so on but
here's a klein bottle that's completely
filled with water
and if i lift it up
at first it'll
notice now when i take my hand off the
bottom
a little bit dribbles out but not too
much
can you put water in a klein bottle you
betcha in
our physical universe
problem of course is
you know water
can also
be taken out
the real problem though is this
once you get water in there
yeah you can get almost all of it out by
tilting it
and sort of doing the opposite of what
you did before
tilt and pour tilt and dribble out yeah
that works
so you get water in and kind of shake it
out
the problem is the last few drops of
water
oh there's not much air circulation
inside of
a physical klein bottle
as a result the last few drops of water
that surface tension holds there
do i have an example probably not very
visible on the video but there's
droplets of water in here
you can
well
getting the last few drops out
means overcoming surface tension
hard to do
so
to remove the last few drops
i'll let this sit in a dis dish drain
for
oh an hour or three a little bit of
water will collect there
i'll pour it out
then
to
you know
get it nice and dry on the outside
the little bit of water still in there
i'll either
pour acetone in swish it around pour it
out
and then let the acetone evaporate
pour alcohol in
that'll work or
intubate it with an aquarium air pump
and pump air through it let the water
evaporate
this
he says
isn't this the same thing that's why you
do the astronomy after all it's not
going to make you rich it's not going to
make you famous it's not going to get
your girls didn't work for me
what it does do is it gets you closer in
touch with the universe